women can't just decide like it's not  fair to just say oh I'm tired I'm not  interested in this anymore I don't need  it and then expect like that is a part  of intimacy that is a part of a marriage  that's really really important and it  your guy is entitled to like want to  have sex with you and to have it  so like I mean honestly like he didn't  get into the marriage if if not then you  should like have a little agreement  beforehand like uh I might not want to  have sex once we get married and I a lot  of guys are going to be like I don't  think I want to do that right so  with that being said it doesn't justify  going out going and cheating what it  does justify is you sitting down with  your wife and saying like this is not  okay with me  um this is not okay and like part of me  being as a man a man is loving you in  all kinds of ways and it's really  important to me and my hope is that it  gets resolved and that she hears you and  understands that